president biden heads to brussels next
week for a summit with nato leaders amid
the growing concerns in ukraine on
friday mr biden had a high-stakes phone
call with chinese president xi jinping
the president made clear the
consequences china could face if it
gives financial assistance to russia its
key ally the chinese president says he
has no plans to send weapons to russia
scott mcfarland has the latest from the
white house this morning scott good
morning michelle good morning to you the
administration is working with other
nations to step up efforts to help
ukraine one day after warning china to
step back
the president left for two days in
delaware following his two-hour phone
call with chinese president xi jinping
vladimir putin has asked the chinese for
drones and economic help as russia copes
with stiff economic sanctions from the
west the white house says president
biden made clear the implication and
consequences of china providing material
support to russia china has to make a
decision for themselves about where they
want to stand
and how they want the history books to
look at them and view their actions
ahead of the president's trip to
brussels defense secretary lloyd austin
visited with u.s and nato troops serving
in bulgaria and slovakia on nato's
eastern flank you were
really demonstrating what this is all
about
what we need to do
in vladimir putin's public appearance
before the flag waving rally at a moscow
stadium he continued his false claims
that the russian invasion was to prevent
genocide
president biden has a word
for this kind of talk
milwaukee
at the united nations a group of western
nations accused russia of a
disinformation campaign including
russia's allegations of biological
warfare labs in ukraine russia has
repeatedly repeatedly accused other
countries of the very violations it
plans to perpetrate
we continue to believe it is possible
that russia may be planning to use
chemical or biological agents against
the ukrainian people
meanwhile back here at the white house
the administration prepares for a big
event monday the start of confirmation
hearings for supreme court nominee judge
katanji brown jackson who completed
dozens of meetings with senators ahead
of the start of those proceedings
jamie big big week ahead scott thank you